a cake dive flowers Galore a variety of
wedding gowns and Deals on it all we
could only be talking about one thing
the bridal spectacular again the bridal
show returns to the expo at World Market
Center this Saturday and Candace Charles
joining us live from Custom cakes for a
sneak peek at the cake that draws the
crowd Candace
good morning you took over the folks yes
I have gloved up and I am ready to go
now this is where all the magic happens
the cake for the diamond dive is made
here I've got a miniature one now
there's no DNR engagement ring the other
house of diamonds provides that
engagement ring it's not in this but
there is something else in there and I
have Amy and apple here Martinez's of
their owners of the Las Vegas Custom
Cakes tell us a little bit about the
cake that's made for the diamond diet so
uh this year we're making a three foot
heart and it's going to be decorated
kind of in this like vintage style okay
popular right now nice um and then we do
hide a few little things in there for
the rights to kind of dig through and
try to find and what does it taste like
it looks very delicious yeah so it's a
really yummy vanilla cake okay um with a
Bavarian cream filling and then vanilla
buttercream awesome I see you guys have
a lot of different types of cakes here
tell us about it
um so we do all kinds of special
occasion cakes we do birthdays weddings
bachelorettes baby showers everything we
also do pastries so we have all kinds of
yummy and delicious things for your
special occasions awesome okay what you
guys have told me about it any tips
before I try to dig into this
um I saw some technique last year where
they rubbed their hands together to try
to find them we'll see if that works
that seemed to work to kind of try to
find it in the case okay here's the
magic let's do this
okay I think I'm kind of close there
goes my hair
um I thought it was in the back uh I'm
just mushing it now guys I'm just doing
a smash at this point
there it is I got it
he helps me thank you I will name me I
appreciate it you guys can try this out
yourself on Saturday bring the girls
bring the hubby have a good time and of
course look at your screen here you can
use that promo code to get 10 bucks off
of your ticket find out more details on
the website 8newsnow.com